comment savoir ce que ça me en 2014
c'est une belle année qui se termine
avec pas mal de controverses
je me suis demandé est-ce que tu te fais
plus appeler samir couleurs pour pas
qu'on sache que c'est toi tu veux ça me
laisse un message non non mais écoutez
en même temps je pense que les cours
traverse
j'avais quand même eu beaucoup c'est pas
ma première s'apprend l'avant pas être
ma dernière on a planifie déjà trois
quêtes qu'est-ce-qui brun qui sent les
épices qui bon à croquer et qui
s'offrent bien à noël
exact j'ai fait un gag sur shawinigan
oui et puis avec tout shawinigan s'est
fâché même le directeur de chambre de
commerce a pris le temps de commenter
sur mon cas il ya deux sortes de
québécois n'a les québécois qui sont
indus qui cultive et bien élevé pita
ceux qui ont voté oui te plaît dans
cette provocation l'appui de ne pas
réagir comme ça mais moi je fais pas
exprès je suis juste ma job - comme
comme humoriste je les dis souvent on
est comme les anthropologues la société
on voit ce qui se passe autour de nous
on le vit qui on doit commenter sur un
brin humoristique avec un accent
humoristique et puis je pense que des
fois c'est pas le gag qui est la
nouvelle c'est la réaction et a eu des
menaces de mort est ce qu'à un moment
donné tu dis ah je vais prendre une
pause le jeu arrêté je vais ralentir le
débit ou l'intensité des vagues pour moi
je sais pas je me suis pas tant due à
des menaces de mort c'est sûr c'est sûr
que c'était la chose la plus intense
mais en même temps je peux pas arrêter
de faire ma job non plus je peux pas
laisser quelque chose mais timide et
comme ça il faut que je fasse ma job
même si j'ai eu des menaces de mort sur
le coup j'ai pas aimé ça c'est sûr ça ça
m'a inquiété
je suis sorti lada avec 2,3 ya tout ce
que j'écris mais avec ça j'ai pas le
choix mais je parle aussi le indy le
punjab y est ce que il ya des
sensibilités vis-à-vis c'est l'anglais
aussi comme nous on en a au québec
vis-à-vis de la langue française
je pense qu'il ya des sensibilités mais
je pense sont pas d'une manière
sociétales comme ça je pense que c'est
sûr que comme moi mes parents
il voulait toujours qu'on parle pour
javier la maison avec eux et ils nous
ont forcés sous qui n'aurait manqué
d'argent trouver la façon j'étais séduit
à aimer le punjab i et lundi c'est en
regardant les films en nba en punjabi la
meilleure façon de faire rayer les
français c'est de créer les produits
culturels qui vont faire en sorte que
les gens vont vouloir regarder ces
choses là france est pour moi une 2d
et fierté c'est le spectacle 100%
français que beaucoup d'anglophones
deviendront beaucoup d'alphand bien de
voir aussi le show ségo lot c'est la
première fois les gens j'aime beaucoup
ce commentaire là c'est la première fois
que les allophones peas anglophone
regardent la télévision en français je
vois les gens qui l'ont acculé de poids
mais la langue française de paul-émile
québec mais tu aurais tu avais pas
besoin de faire carrière au québec en
français toi tu avais déjà une carrière
internationale
donc est ce que tu as des regrets
finalement d'avoir décidé de lancer en
français ou non pourquoi d'importants
achats d'or face en français pour moi
c'est c'est c'est une chose que j'ai
toujours voulu faire puis je me suis dit
est ce que mon jeu me suisse comme en
france est d'assez bon pour faire
l'umons là dedans moi je sortis qu'une
française sont en colère c'est pas tant
à se mettre dans paris va compter c'est
8 et 10 août kaunas j'étais quand même
été la seule connaît ce que j'ai je m'en
vais faire la france grâce à ça bientôt
je m'en vais embêter les français ah oui
déjà ton une pub la même chose quand je
vais aux états unis je me moque des
américains
quand je vais en angleterre je me moque
des britanniques puis il aime ça et
s'ils ont une culture de venir nous
taquiner là quand je marche je m'en vais
en france j'ai déjà mon opening que j'ai
écrit je commence jeudi vous savez j'ai
fait ma carrière au québec comme avait
dans le choix de continuer aux états
unis ou de faire la france puis moi j'ai
choisi la france parce qu aux etats-unis
après le 11-septembre
ils ont commencé à maltraiter les arabes
tandis que vous vous l'avez toujours
faire on sait à quoi s'attendre ici
je souhaite que les gens qui viennent à
mon spectacle qui voit que je ta poche
soit inclus parce que moi j'ai appris a
longtemps qu'il faut juste payer les
latinos une fois que la job est fait je
me moque de tout le monde
on dirait qu'il ya juste un flou qui est
surveillé 24 heures sur votre caf biya
mais en même temps on dirait qu'il ya
quelque chose d'intéressant aussi comme
humoriste de voir cette dynamique être
une minorité visible dans une société
qui se dit une minorité dans l'amérique
du nord il ya quand même des enjeux là
dedans comme humoriste qui devient
intéressant liens d'amitié dont avec
pauline marois f qu' il y avait beaucoup
de taquineries la danse cirque avec des
capes et où d'autres politiciens
nouvellement élu tu t'amuses bah c'est
sûr j'ai envie d'en faire des gangs
on en a vu plein sur jean charest sur
stephen harper savoir si tu en fais
super copé mais là ça devient autre
débat de société pour noël tu voulais
une plainte officielle de l'office
québécois de la langue française
qu'est ce qu'on souhaite pour le nouvel
an pour le nouvel an continue à faire
des spectacles au québec continuer à
ajouter des supplémentaires on s'envoie
jusqu'en 2016 au québec et puis après ça
fait de souhaiter que j'allais en
battant embêter nos cousins français
il sait si bien faire ça oui merci